[Music]
so
hi everyone and uh welcome to
jankbusters uh i'm tom wilsias i'm a
product manager on the chrome graphics
team yeah i'm nat i hack on the
rendering system write code stuff like
that and we're here today to talk about
jank uh on the web what it is and and
how to fight it
yeah so
what we usually do when we talk about
jank is we sort of start with like what
smoothness is right so you've got a
screen in front of you a lot of you do
and uh the way that things working right
is it's tricking your eye into
perceiving motion when in fact what it's
doing is it's updating the screen those
lcds really really really fast once
every
60 60 of a second now sometimes it's
like 50 hertz sometimes it's 54. uh it's
all over the map but the idea is you've
got to do it fast enough so your eye
perceives this as movement and if you do
so then it's smooth
uh if you don't then you get jank yeah
and gent comes in in in a whole variety
of formats we refer to something as a
hitch when you drop a whole bunch of
frames in a row so say everything stops
for 200 milliseconds or a low frame rate
is when maybe things are still still
happening routinely but they're not
happening as often as they should be so
you only get a new frame up every 50
milliseconds instead of every 16
milliseconds that kind of thing and the
worst is when these things combine and
you get you get a really variable frame
rate you get new frames coming up on the
screen at irregular intervals your eye
is really well attuned to that sort of
irregularity because it's how we notice
motion and if you you look at something
that's supposed to stick to your finger
right like something like say this div
that's scrolling up and down it's pretty
fast because this resolution is a little
smaller than the monitors like try this
on a high-res device or a low-end
computer
then then you'll see that once that
physical metaphor gets broken of your
finger moving and the screen updating
sort of correspondingly then all of a
sudden things start to feel really bad
right and this is the difference between
something that feels smooth and feels
really nice and responsive and something
that feels janky and this is what we're
talking about when we talk about jack
yeah i mean basically you know we all
talk about it's all well well
established right you've got to optimize
your you know loads minify do this do
that make sure that you're you know
doing the right request to your network
but there's the second class citizen
right which is the rendering system
which we haven't typically had to think
about because you know frankly the old
web pages of yesterday you move up and
down right and the browser can do lots
of tricks to make that just fast but
nowadays when you have you know complex
beautiful looking websites for those to
feel native for those to stick to your
finger
the thing you have to do is you have to
run calculation of layout you have to
run javascript you might garbage collect
somewhere in there you might have some
animation that you have to do you might
accidentally query a style select do you
want to interrupt yeah like say
something similar so it's really it's
really hard right like there's a lot
that needs to go into that 16
milliseconds and that is rattling off
this list of things but it's it
what we're here today to talk about is
the stuff that i guess i would summarize
as the green bars in in chrome step
tools right so yes there are a whole
wide variety of things that you can
think about when you're thinking about
performance and that includes all the
the network latency stuff that's talking
about it includes a lot of javascript
events uh but what we're here today to
discuss is what we call rendering and
that sort of breaks down into painting
and compositing and we're gonna talk
about both and in fact uh there was a
really cool post uh by paul lewis just
today where he said i bet you that if
you go to your favorite website out
there um you will see a whole lot of
green and purple
in in the modern web and i would
encourage you to give that a try and i
think you'll find there's a lot of
websites out there that are basically
paint and this green bound that's what
we're here to talk to you about that's
jank busting yeah so
how do you jank bust uh first step is
you try to paint fast right try to get
those green bars to be as short as
possible we're gonna talk a little bit
about how to do that but better yet
you're going to try not to paint at all
we're going to talk about about that in
in probably greater detail and lastly
we're going to go into a few cases where
because the platform is not always as
obvious as it might be you end up
painting when you really don't have to
and and you might not even be noticing
this kind of thing because it's the sort
of thing that you need to use tools to
sort of proactively look for but we'll
show you how to do that and we'll show
you how to hopefully get a better
glimpse into what's going on under the
hood so you've heard us use the word
paint right and i think that's really
the building block here that we need to
talk a bit more about so you go to you
know goog and you
you get this right which is
a blinking cursor right
earth shattering now what's going on
behind the scenes here is that chrome
has
the cursor is a lie this is not the
operating system doing it chrome has
just a bitmap in memory just of rgb
colors and the cursor is just some dark
colors in that in that bitmap and
blink slash webkit has
uh bookkeeping in it very exhaustive
bookkeeping that says oh this part of
the shadow dom changed i'm going to
repaint
this part of the bitmap because it's
different now and i need to put a cursor
where there wasn't or i need to remove a
cursor that is called a repaint and so
it has a there's a repaint rectangle you
can imagine right when something changes
visually we have to repaint it
and you can sort of imagine that the
cost of a repaint is you know to first
order proportional to how much you have
to repaint so certainly you know
blinking that cursor is going to be a
whole heck of a lot cheaper than
blinking say all of google to black and
white right back and forth
it's just sort of intuitive right you
have to touch more bits of memory but
you know of course that's not the whole
story we could all go home right
the other part of this is that not all
paints are gonna be the same speed so of
course if we want to just fill in a part
of the page with white
it's going to be a lot cheaper but if we
go to this i'm feeling lucky button and
you actually like really look at it
actually i think this audience more than
anybody understands sort of the the
details in some of these elements
all of those little effects you see the
the anti-aliasing on the text
the rounded corner the
line being anti-aliased all of those
things are costly and they're costly in
the sense that they eat cpu in order to
perform the computer you know the cpu
just has to sit there going oh is this
line on the pixel or halfway on the
pixel and it just you know noms away at
the cpu so the i'm feeling lucky button
is three or four times slower to paint
than just a white area and this sort of
makes sense and then if you go to a low
end device like a phone it's even more
uh that that difference is even more
amplified
so this is all sort of
my long-winded way of saying don't paint
right like don't do it and and in
particular if you're thinking about
mobile really really don't do it
and to help you with this
we built into the browser and not just
we chrome
pretty much all browsers now have this
concept of a layer right uh the best way
to think about layers is we look at you
know your dom and we go oh this this
thing is an over scroll div like an
overflow scroll div uh you're probably
gonna move that up and down right so
hey let's let's instead of instead of
repainting in order to make that scroll
happen let's take that thing and make it
into sort of like a photoshop layer
right and we can move the layer up and
down
right and fake it out and then what
we'll do is we'll store the contents of
that layer
on the gpu
and then when we actually just do an
action on the page that moves the
document up and down like this all that
you have to do is ask the gpu to
composite
so now in modern chrome you'll see two
steps in the in the timeline you see
paints which you don't want to do
and you see composites the composites
are us taking these layers and smashing
them down
and if you do that chrome can really hit
some super super high smooth frame rate
60 hertz whatever it is if you don't do
it
and you paint then you're in trouble
right so i'm going to walk you through
sort of an
example of that scrolling
working well or not
this is a site it's pretty simple
it's a list of 100 images uh and you can
see that uh again
demos might be slightly off modulo the
the resolution being slightly smaller
than what's normally on this laptop but
this scrolls pretty smoothly i can like
fling up and down in this area no
problem you can see that the scroll
thumb on the right side is updating like
really nicely and
i'm i would not call this janky right
but you'll notice that as i'm doing this
i've got the mouse cursor sitting in the
gutter of the page
and if i mouse over one of these images
i've got like
a simple animation effect that happens
just based on like the hover pseudo
pseudo class right and i get a little
bit of a drop shadow i brighten the
image a little bit
nothing nothing all that fancy but uh it
is it is an effect that changes things a
little bit it's a you know two or three
lines of what you'll see is very
destructive css exactly and you'll see
that if if i try to do that same scroll
it's pretty fast here if i try to do
that same scroll with the the mouse and
over the images um then
all of a sudden things start to kind of
fall apart and the difference is
something that i'm going to show you
right now if you open up dev tools and
you turn on show paint rectangles which
is like our beloved feature in devtools
you can you can see what the difference
is the difference is whether or not
you're painting during the scroll so if
i just move up and down now
what's happening is that chrome's
pre-painted a little bit behind the
scenes and it can pre-paint about fast
enough
that
you don't actually get paint operations
that happen when you actually need to
show new content on screen and so that
means i can sit here scrolling up and
down and i don't get any red rectangles
which are the areas that are being
repainted just like the blinking cursor
from before so this is that layer
analogy right in this case the layer
analogy is working well right you're not
seeing any repaints it means that you're
going nice and fast you'll hit 60 hertz
in fact the only thing repainting you'll
notice is the scroll bar on the right
hand side there and there's no helping
that if i mouse over one of these uh
images you can see that throughout the
throughout the course of that that hover
effect i animate in and out
uh the classes i'm changing and i'm
getting repaints sort of every frame of
those of those effects uh animating and
that's that's really really painful
right not only is it making the
animation run a little bit slow
in theory if i if i do this
and scroll up and down all of a sudden
i'm having all these red rectangles
flash during the scroll operation yeah
we saw this happen on a popular photo
blogging site thing where you can sort
of guess what it was where basically
they have this nice hover effect and if
you had your cursor in the wrong place
the site was just completely unusable
yeah
and and so i mean
hover is something we're picking on here
but
is actually relatively simple to deal
with if scrolling performance is
important to you you can turn off the
hover effect during scroll right like i
can achieve that with an on scroll
handler and a timer and indeed if i do
so you'll notice that i don't get the
repaints
during the scroll but then as soon as
the scroll stops i sort of get them
again 200 milliseconds after the last
scroll event and that's great right but
it does change the ux of the site a
little bit and this is the kind of thing
that you need to start sort of
reorienting yourself reorienting
yourself to think about when you think
about design right because you can do
some really nice visual effects on the
web today but it's also really easy to
shoot yourself in the foot performance
wise and
i'm going to just sort of assert that
things like good scrolling performance
are actually just as critical to the
design and feel of your site as really
nice visuals are
i'm going to assert that as well just to
be with him
right so again i'm picking on hover like
the point here is not use hover the
point here is use dev tools to see
what's going on right so there there are
a wide variety of ways to get paints
that you don't necessarily need or want
during a scroll they include some of the
things on this list and if you do get
paints during a scroll it's not
necessarily a problem right like it's
entirely conceivable that the paints can
be so fast that
you can afford the paint and the texture
upload to the gpu and the composite and
whatever else goes into the rendering
pipeline but just don't paint like don't
get into a dangerous situation just
don't paint because there are a lot of
things that can make make the paints
take a long time right and like yeah the
rounded corners and drop shadows and the
other effects that we're all sort of
familiar with can play into this but
there can be a lot of other things that
are a lot more subtle um our the bane of
our existence right now
in in this category is is definitely
image decodes um because it's really
possible especially on high resolution
screens to blow a lot of the internal uh
image decode caches inside of blank
slash webkit and then like everything so
so this slide don't don't sit there
scrolling down you know scribbling down
this slide or like whatever you know we
we're constantly changing our minds in
chrome and screwing up and chrome has a
very tiny brain and it gets really
confused really easily so this is the
current list of
bad things
but the best thing to do is pay
attention to the techniques we're
showing you to measure the source of
jank and then sort of deal with the
latest canary of whatever whatever the
thing is at the time
exactly and
the the layer model that we're talking
about that's so great for scrolling all
of this applies to other types of
animation too uh there's nothing sort of
special about scrolling other than that
we've put sort of an extraordinary
amount of work into trying to make that
particular i mean we kind of scroll a
lot on the web yeah because because it's
so common but like a lot of the same
primitives or what we use to try to make
things like say css animation also work
well so if i open up
this demo this is
super ugly
uh we're not designers um but
we're trying you'll see that this is
just a drawer right this animates in and
out it's using css animation so great
right like i'm using modern techniques
i'm telling the browser what i'm trying
to be doing it should just make things
good for me right well kind of but
the way css animation works you can
actually you can animate all sorts of
stuff right and there are things that
you can animate that don't play very
well at all with this notion of
everything needing to fit into 16
millisecond frames for instance what if
you need to do a lot of reflow during
during the animation right that means
that every time a new position ticks out
of this animation running stuff could be
like moving around and that's the kind
of thing that blank slash webkit gets
really really bad at really fast so if
i that was cool
surprise
if i open up dev tools again and i have
show paint racks on then you can see
that during this animation i'm actually
painting every single frame of it again
that red flash that means repaint and
that's bad that's really bad for
animation
and you can even see that it's a little
it's a little jerky right all i'm
animating here is the left property and
if i had say text in the middle you
would see it reflowing and stuff and and
that reflow is is really really
negative for performance if i open up
the devtools timeline and i take a
recording
of that animation running
you can guess what you're going to see
but if i zoom in here i get like style
recalculation relay out paint operations
composite layer operations and on that
paint thing we'll basically if you take
this to a low end machine that paint can
balloon to 30 40 50 60 milliseconds you
know in a blink of an eye you put an
image on there you put some shadow on
there you put a border you sneeze um
bang there goes your 16 milliseconds and
and you might be saying like well the
wouldn't it be great if the browser
could kind of make this better for me
but again there's something kind of
fundamental to the way the left property
works that makes that hard because
elements elements flow right so instead
if i use something like a webkit
transform this is probably a trick
you've
screwed my demo this is probably a trick
you've read about online right like
these transforms promote things to their
own layer so the layers we're talking
about for scrolling earlier they apply
here too and if i run this animation
using
a translate x for my transform instead
of the left property then all of a
sudden those red rectangles go away
during the animation and that's great
right because that means i'm not i'm not
painting anymore and indeed i can
confirm this if i go back to timeline
take a recording run the animation
stop it
look at what's going on here all i'm
seeing are composite layer operations
and the reason that we can get away with
this is because the transform takes the
element out of out of flow right and and
it lets us sort of make some guarantees
about the thing inside the transform
being kind of independent from
the the sort of parent container and
that's that's really nice um but you'll
notice there's
not quite done yet right because i'm
still seeing these red flashes at the
beginning and end of the animation and
this is the kind of thing that if you're
thinking with 16 millisecond frames in
in sort of the forefront of your mind
should should stand out as potentially
problematic right because that means
that as soon as i click the button a
repaint's going to happen and if that
repaint might be slow then all of a
sudden there's this lag when i click the
button right and that sucks that's
that's really bad that's not what you
want at all you want things to feel
really responsive you want them to
respond immediately as soon as you see
the other the other kind of responsive
right right
and so
it it so happens that there's a
relatively easy way around this um in
that if you use a translate 3d instead
of a translate x the thing gets promoted
to a layer all the time if i
want to illustrate this i can use
a great feature of dev tools
called show composited layer borders
and
if i turn that on you see this sort of
cyan grid the grid's not important what
is important is the sort of yellowish
orange border that goes around the
viewport in this case and that yellow
orange border means everything inside of
this is in its own layer so these layers
that we keep talking about here's a way
to sort of visualize them and if you
look at what happens
as i run that animation you can kind of
see again if i zoom in that
the drawer gets a yellow orange border
of its own throughout the course of the
animation
but if i make the red rec go away the
repaint go away you'll notice that there
isn't any yellow orange border before or
after the animation
and that's bad right and that's the
reason that you get those red flashes
the repaints
right at the beginning and right at the
end because what happens is that i start
the animation
the drawer gets ripped out put in its
own layer this is a new layer so now
chrome needs to paint
the thing that didn't exist before right
that takes arbitrarily long and then we
recomposite recomposite re-composite the
animation runs and then we smush the
drawer back into the base layer of the
page when we smush it back into the base
layer of the page we have to repaint
that area and that's why you get the
second red flash at the at the end if i
use the the translate 3d instead of the
translate x this is sort of incidental
but you you don't get those
it has to
you get yeah
it has a tiny brain so it gets confused
right
it's a well-meaning brain
you'll see that now there's this sort of
uh
orangish border
even when the animation isn't running
this is what we call sometimes
pre-promotion because the layer is like
we promote the drawer to its own layer
at all times so if you have something
that you think will move in the future
you need to start thinking about not
giving it a layer at the last second
like in the on click but having it have
a layer well in advance so that it's
already primed up and ready to go so
that when you get that on click it just
starts moving and open means fast right
and you might be thinking this feels
really hacky and you would be you would
you would be correct yeah this is this
is the platform right now and it stinks
sorry but but it is something we're also
actively changing because for instance
the the translate x example i have in
the latest canary is it actually stopped
working as a bad example because uh when
there's a webkit transition or a
transition property uh on the the drawer
element we actually are now teaching
blink to be smart enough to
uh actually
pre-promote the thing on its own but you
need to think about this because it's
just you don't assume that the platform
will get it right yet someday maybe but
not yet exactly so
that is layers for animation but
sometimes you need to see more than that
and that's going to show you yeah i mean
we like giving you eye strain with the
yellow lines those thin little yellow
lines that are absolutely critical for
performance like that's really nice
right
so what what we've done is we've built
an internal tool
this is quite a bit more technical than
say
uh
you know dev tools but what it will do
is it'll let you see your layering so
here i just have a
you know
cats search
and uh when you use chrome's frame
viewer and you can google it to find
info on this um what you get is you get
a list of frames that were drawn by the
by the compositor
so for example here
and then what you can end up with
is this which if you remember my gmail
slide that showed the gmail layers well
this is this but for your site so
these are your layers in your site and
just to give you sort of a more you know
complex example we've got you know
plus and here's plus here and the
interesting thing here is
as you scroll if the viewport sticks
there it is
over there
you can see sort of there's a viewport
here
up there
right and then we've got the content for
everything below the page and so in this
case as you go between your pages what
you'll see is the actual viewport moving
you'll see the layers
stuff like that and this can end up
being very useful because you can pull
things out like
why a layer was created
and
you know how much gpu memory it's using
it's sort of advanced stuff but if you
really are going to try to push your
content to the limits of the current
platform you may want to check this sort
of thing out particularly on mobile
where you run into things like memory
memory constraints a lot more readily
yeah um this is kind of what we're
pushing we're gonna we're gonna be
pretty brief on that though it's a
pretty low level tool but grab us if
you're yeah we're happy to talk about it
more uh later on um
last category of stuff we want to talk
about which is which is that there are
times when you can get one of these
these repaint flashes
even if it seems like you didn't deserve
it and this can happen in all sorts of
scenarios but i'll walk you through one
um
if i click this button i add a div to a
container pretty simple fantastic it's
100 100 pix square nothing complicated
at all about this styling right um and
if i open up dev tools and i have the
the repaint rex on i'm going to turn off
the layer borders have the repaint
wrecks on as i as i click
to add more you can see that i'm sort of
repainting where the button is and i'm
repainting where
the
the new divs are and as i get sort of
off screen adding more i can sit here
all day matching this button and the
only thing that repaints is well the
scroll bar and the button right this is
great this kind of makes sense it's it's
intuitive to think that well if i'm
changing something in the dom but it's
only affecting things that are off
screen shouldn't need to repaint right
and
that's great when it works but
unfortunately
repaints don't only happen when you make
changes that end up with visual impact
it's entirely possible to do something
like say
toggle the padding
on this container block that you can see
outlined in black
and when you do that
you end up repainting the entire
container
and again if you think about it a little
longer maybe this makes sense again
because from blink's perspective what
happened you added a little bit of
padding but potentially everything
inside reflowed right this is like the
beauty of of the web and
when that happens all bets are off about
the content inside of the container
blink needs to be very very conservative
about maintaining like what might be
dirty what might be out of date and we
have to repaint and when we repaint this
is what you get so it's really important
to think about this in terms of like
it can blink can get confused and it
gets confused very easily so you have to
monitor this cert monitor for this sort
of thing
during your development there are ways
with chrome developer tools protocol to
get the paint stream out so that you can
monitor and test harnesses for example
but you need to keep an eye on this sort
of thing because stupid innocuous stuff
like setting width to the same thing
that it used to be can sometimes cause
this
and and then it'll you know ruin your
day and this is the kind of thing that
again we're trying to make better all
the time but there are always going to
be pitfalls like this so it's the kind
of thing you need to sort of watch out
for
yeah but i mean ultimately there are
just times when you do your best you've
got you know everything done as well as
you can but you do have to paint
sometimes that's you've added something
to the dom and you actually really do
need to paint it and sometimes it's just
an effect that you're just not willing
to compromise on you know there it might
be the g-whiz thing that you've done you
know who knows what it is but it happens
so we we started off with uh
with sort of this this thing up right
and um it's a little jankier when you go
full screen and blah blah blah so we're
showing you this is sort of
an example of bad content right chrome
has a feature called continuous
repainting mode or devtools does so
if i check this button here
and go back now what
chrome is doing is it's constantly
repainting so it's a little hard to see
but basically there
the whole page has gone a little red and
that's because it's got a big repaint
rectangle on all of it
and what's happening here is chrome's
constantly
re-repainting all the time as fast as it
can go and up here is the number in the
top right the the paint speed that we're
sustaining so this is assuming that
you've just you know you've confused
blink and it's going horribly so uh when
i unplug projector here this goes at
like 167 milliseconds
the idea here though is you can sit
there now in dev tools we're going to
have to play some window size acrobatics
here
to get that up on the screen okay
so
we have another piece of
uh you know feature addition to dev
tools which is the h key on the element
panel super super you know the top
secret
yeah uh we're living large so we've got
this h key and what it does is it hides
that element and everybody that descends
from it and if you watch that number
that's being reported we're going from a
big number to a really really trivial
number not to zero and that sort of
makes sense we've still got to set the
page to this
lovely pew color right
um
so
but it's it's cheaper so we can go oh
well clearly this tells us that the
thing that slow painting is inside my
body
so this is simple it's just a bunch of
image you know tags so
uh i can do the same trick with styles
so i can hide the box shadow and now
we're really cranking we're going at
what like eight milliseconds right so
now we sort of have this idea that well
maybe 22 of those milliseconds or watch
me do math
some some amount of that is going to the
drop shadow right
um we can bring it back on and turn off
the border radius and you can see that
well
maybe it's that one right now these
don't always compose sometimes you can
fuse chrome so like if i remove
both of them we're not really going
incrementally much faster so what's
happening here is you're hitting a
particular corner case in chrome's
rendering system where
the comp is the composition of these two
different styles is particularly slow
don't go home and say hey this is this
this is one to avoid because we may fix
this tomorrow right we probably won't
but
we might
uh
again keep the technique in mind we've
found a lot of sites where there's one
effect uh that's particularly slow now
not to rag on gmail but uh in gmail
there's a little drop shadow between the
top bar and the uh the message list and
there's a little drop shadow that's uh
like a half pixel
uh and that costs a third of the
rendering time of the entire page
uh this is important to factor into your
design discussions right this is a back
and forth that you need to be having
early on so that you don't get a week
away from ship and go oh my god we can't
we can't afford this oh my god we're up
we're up a creek
so continuous painting mode definitely
check it out we also have more fanciness
coming in that
high tech tool some of you may have seen
in the blog sphere about ski a debugger
and some magic you can play that will
start showing up in the frame viewer so
more coming
that's right
so
to wrap up uh again
our main takeaway here is tools uh you
want to ask yourself a couple key
questions when you're debugging site
performance you want to ask yourself why
you're painting well first you want to
notice that you're painting using show
paint wrecks you and then you want to
ask yourself why you want to see if you
can avoid it either through judicious
use of layers or by just trying to not
touch the dom unnecessarily and if you
really can't avoid it then you want to
make it as fast as possible using tools
like continuous painting mode
and it's especially important because
chrome's changing a lot
so you know be familiar with what
currently is bad because it'll change
again
and also keep in mind that your computer
that you're probably developing on is a
really good one i see a lot of sort of
good machines out there right um that is
not what mon paw have and that is most
of the web
so keep that in mind when you get
something going at you know seven or
eight milliseconds on your computer know
that that's two or three or eight times
slower yeah out on the real world or
like shrink outputs or whatever and a
really good number to walk away from is
uh or walk away with is wikipedia if you
just do like the cats page on wikipedia
i think it takes about 150 milliseconds
to paint um on a nexus 7. so
that is
not jank free right so you know keep
this stuff in mind exactly
uh so uh with that i'm not sure we have
time for questions um but this talk and
other uh sort of resources just a bunch
of bunch of links to to similar content
is all up on jankfree.org which is a
site we maintain um a lot of that
content actually lives on html5 rocks
which is the chrome sort of developer
relations website our contact info is up
here
if you have thoughts on any of this
we're always happy to talk about it
and we like talking to developers
shoulder to cry on yeah we'll be around
tonight too if anyone has a site that's
slow or whatever we can we can take a
look thank y'all and thank you very much
[Applause]
you